[Müzik]
çok havalı girdim ya hak ediyor muydun
bu havayı Merhabalar
[Müzik]
acayip kalabalık çok heyecanlıyım benim
mazur görün
ben takdimdeki gibi Tolga
bir yeni Medya Ajansı ve farklı
girişimlerim var
Şimdi size bugün şansla ilgili Konuşmaya
geldim Çünkü etrafında bana
şanslı diyen çok insan var
size de var mı Mesela şanslısın sen çok
şanslı birisin
Mesela
bu şansı anlamaya başladığımda bir Yeni
Kapı açıldığını gördüm ve Aslında bugün
burada bunu anlatmak istedim ben
hayatımda şanslı mıyım bunu düşünmeye
başladım Çünkü
bulunduğum ortamla yaptığım işle
sahip olduklarımla şanslı bulunan
biriyim dedim ya ben hakikaten şanslı
mıyım acaba
Her bu
şanslı mıyım dediğimde aklıma dünyanın
en komik diyaloğu geliyor
bir evlilik programında belki aranızda o
videoyu izlemiş olan vardır Ben şu an
şanslı mıyım diyen adam
bir gelin adayı var Damat adayı gidiyor
yanına gelin adayı damat adayın çok
istiyor ama
diyor ki beni bulduğun için çok
şanssızsın
Adam da diyor ki Ben şu an şanslı mıyım
sonra bunu defalarca tekrar etmeye
başlıyor takılmış gibi kadına bakıyor
Ben şu an şanslı mıyım ya diyor
etrafından onay bekliyor gerçekten ben
şu an şanslı biriyim dedim de aklımda
hep bu konuyu düşünürken Ben şu an
şanslı mıyım ya şans Kanka Göreceli bir
şey aslında değil mi
ama
Eğer
göreceli olmasaydı Ya da biz şans sanki
Göreceli bir şeymiş gibi davranmasaydık
ne olurdu
hiç düşündünüz mü bunu aranızda şanslı
olduğunu düşünen var mı
Ben şanslı biriyim
Güzel fena bir kalabalık değil güzel
Peki bu şanslı bilinçli olarak
yönettiğinizi düşünüyor musunuz biraz
buna gidelim Bakalım orada ne var şanslı
olduğunu düşünmeyen İnsanlar neden
şanssız olduğunu düşünüyor şanslılar
bunu nasıl beceriyor
Robocop gibi elimde iki tane kumanda var
inşallah Becereceğim bunu
şimdi şansın kelime anlamına baktım
tdk'dan
mantıkla açıklanamayan Bir takım
rastlantısal olayların nedeni olan güç
baht
tarih Felek
ha Feleğin çarkına diyoruz ya şanssız
olduğumuzu hissettiğimizde Felek Peki
şimdi feleği nasıl Çarkıfelek olarak
nasıl çevirebiliriz ona bakacağız
şimdi ben bu tanıma hem katılıyorum hem
katılmıyorum katıldığım yer
Evet mantıklı açıklanamayabilir ama
bence mantıkla yönetilebilir
yani mantığınızı kullanıp daha şanslı
biri olabilirsiniz
Şimdi mesela doğru zamanda doğru yerde
olmak diye bir şey vardır değil mi Bunu
çok fazla yönetemeyiz aslında yani eğer
oradaysak olmuşuzdur değilsek değilizdir
Peki o yüzden bunu çok fazla bir
parametre olarak Mantık parametresi
olarak almayalım
Evet burada Peki başka mantık
parametresi olmayan ne var
mesela
doğru yönlendirilmiş olabilirsiniz daha
çocuk yaşta yani aileniz size bir
yetenek kazandırmış olabilir okul spor
sanat bu konuda yönlendirilmiş
olabilirsiniz veya
her şeyi yapacak kadar imkanınız vardır
şanslısınızdır İşte
keşfedilmiş bir yeteneğiniz vardır daha
8 yaşında inanılmaz piyano
çalıyorsunuzdur falan Bunlar başlangıç
opsiyonel şanslar
olmak zorunda değil Hatta şöyle diyeyim
başarılı insanların hikayelerine bakın
çoğu zaman bu şansların hiçbiri yok
niye yok bu şanslar Madem başarılı
insanlar genel olarak şanslı insanlar
bunlar yok hatta tam tersi büyük dramlar
var büyük sıkıntılar var kaoslar var
çözümsüz problemler var hatta fiziksel
engeller var
buna baktığınızda şunu görmeniz çok
kolay aslında
çözüm üretmek
zorunda kalmadan yaptığınız bir şey mi
niye zorunda olmadığım zaman çözüm
üreteyim ki
O zaman çözüm üretiyorum çözüm ürettikçe
yaratıcılığım gelişiyor Eğer bir yerde
bir kaos yoksa
kaosu yönetebilir misiniz
sabrınız nasıl gelişecek Eğer bir yerde
risk yoksa risk alabilir misiniz
bunları Zaten yönete yönete bu çözümleri
bula bula yaratıcı olmuyor muyuz
yani temelde
sorunlar
çözüm
bekliyor ve o çözümler bizi Daha
yaratıcı Daha yaratıcı Daha yaratıcı
hale getiriyor peki
günde
kendi hayatımızdaki Krizlere dönelim
sanki şans deyince hep şunu anlıyoruz ya
dış etkenler Peki Kendi bedenimizde
kendi yeteneklerimizle kendi
sıkıntılarımızla nasıl bir ilişki
içerisindeyiz
mesela Bazen ben çok karşılaşıyorum ben
şunu yapamıyorum diyor Okey ama
yapabildiğin de şunlar var değil mi
Ah Evet öyle bakmadım
E sen bir açıdan şanslısın aslında ama
şanssızlıklarına bakıyor olabilirim size
ya da dış etkenleri sürekli suçluyor
diyor ki şu yerin de değil ülke Şu halde
o bilmem ne bu bilmem ne falan E peki
senin çözüm Üretmen gereken o zaman
Tonlarca şey var hadi geliştir
yaratıcılığını Hadi göster bize o zaman
Ben bunu metodik olarak
şansı arttırma yöntemini anlatacağım Bu
nedir
şansı yönetmektir Aslında şans seni
yönetebileceğim bir şey bence
nasıl yönetebilirsin şansı
çok basit bir yöntem anlatacağım size
Eğer bir şans olacaksa ortada bir konu
olması lazım
durduğun evde Yattığın yerden bir şans
beklemek dünyanın en saçma ortaya bir
konu at değil mi Hangi konuda şanslı
olacaksın Şimdi sen hangi konu senin
ilgini çekiyor Tamam konuyu buldu bir
ihtimal yaratman lazım ortada hareket
yoksa ihtimal yok
bir şeyler
bir ihtimaller koyman lazım ortaya şunu
yapabilirim bunu yapabilirim bunu
yapabilirim bunu yapabilirim güzel
daha sonra
bunu ihtimalleri denemeye
başlayabilirsin
herhangi bir ihtimali denersin sonra
diğer ihtimali denersin diğer ihtimalde
dersin
karşılıkları aldın mı Şimdi bunu tekrar
etmeye başlarsın tekrar tekrar tekrar
başarılı insanların yine her şeyi tek
seferde yaptığını düşünüyor insanlar
binlerce tekrar olduğunun onun arkasında
binlerce başarısızlık yüzlerce yanlış
karar olduğunu unutuyorlar
Aslında çok ciddi bir deneme çok ciddi
bir yanılma var oradan çıkan
onlarca yüzlerce binlerce sonuç ve
tecrübe var ama şans
bunların genel ismi oluyor bir anda
şanslı çünkü şanslı hayır konuyu
belirledi ihtimalleri yarattı
denedi
tekrar denedi tekrar denedi tekrar
peki
ihtimaller var ben sürekli yanlış
olanları seçiyorum
bırakmayacaksın denemeye devam edeceksin
ta ki bir ihtimal çalışana kadar
şimdi
denedim ve bazılarında başarılı oldum bu
anlattığım şey kendi hayatımda aynı
zamanda Ben Etrafımdaki insanlar bana
diyor ki sen niye bu kadar sektörde Bu
kadar iş yapıyorsun
deniyorum
denemesi bedava değil mi
deneyebilirim yani deniyorum ve bunu bir
dağılmak olarak görmüyorum konuyu
belirliyorum
ihtimalleri belirliyorum denemeye
başlıyorum bazılarında hiç başarılı
olamıyorum yok ediyorum başarılı
olduklarında devam ediyorum Sonra onları
daha fazla deniyorum ve daha sonra bir
şey yapıyorum Aslında
konuları da arttırıyorum
konuları arttırmak ne demek
Yani ortada bir konu var ve onun
ihtimalleri onun tekrarları ve onun
tecrübeleri var mesela bambaşka bir
sektörde bambaşka bir şey deniyorum yeni
bir konu atıyorum ortaya
ve Aslında buna
Siz çok alışıksınız bankacılık
sektöründen
portföy oluşturma dediğimiz şey bu
Sen hayatında bir portföy yöneticisi
olabilirsin
Yanlış mıyım
portföy yönetmek ne demek bir tanesi iyi
gider bir tanesi kötü gider biri baş
aşağı Trend alır biri baş yukarı trende
alır Sen ne yaparsın birinden zarar
edersin birinden kar edersin birinde çok
mutlu olursun birinde Mutsuz olursun ama
totalde şansa alan yaratırsın
biri alır Rüzgarı gider bir tanesi o
kadar da Rüzgar alamaz ama sen kendi
hayatının portföy yöneticisisin aslında
Sadece buna bu kadar teknik bakmıyorsun
bir konu belirlemiyorsun ihtimalleri
arttırmıyorsun deneyip bunu tekrar
tekrar
bununla uğraşmıyorsun sonra da ben
şanssızım diyorsun Hayır sen şanslı alan
yaratmıyorsun aslında
veya şanslı olduğunu düşünüyorsan da
okey güzel demek bunları yapıyorsun
veya Tek seferlik Bir şey geldi önüne
Bence dünyanın en kötü şansı ne biliyor
musunuz
kaynağını bilmediğin bir değeri birine
vermek
o kaynağını bilmediği değeri alan adam
kendini şanslı hissediyor ama bence
dünyanın en şanssız adamı birine en
büyük kötülük bu kaynağını bilmediği bir
değer vermek ona Eğer şans konusuna bir
metot olarak bakmazsan elinde olan şansı
iyi kullanma imkanının neredeyse yok
O yüzden şanslı olmayı da doğru
algılamak gerekiyor şanssız olmayı da
şimdi konuları arttırdım
farklı alanlar belirledim ve o alanlarda
da aynı döngüyü yaratmaya başladım
ve artık bir portföyüm var dediğim gibi
artık her yerden şansa yarattığım
alanlara farklı balıklar
farklı balıkları yakalıyorum farklı
alanlarda Bir Mükemmel gidiyor Biri
farklı gidiyor ve
şimdi ben burada
başka bir şey söyleyeceğim iki tane
büyük örnek vereceğim size
Global şirketlerden bir tane fastfood
markası var hepimizin adını ezbere
bildiğimiz
bu fast food markası nasıl çalışıyor
biliyor musunuz
french'ını verdiği her Dükkanı satın
alıyor
ve Kim o French satın alansa ona çok
uzun sözleşmelerle kiralıyor
yani
o binanın o dükkanın maliyetini o French
dükkan tamamen gıda işletmesi
ama seneler içerisinde o kadar büyük bir
emlak şirketine dönüşüyor ki
emlağın yarattığı değer ana faaliyetinin
misli ile Üstüne çıkıyor aslında burada
ne var akıllı bir şans yaratma ve bir
portföy yönetimi kafası var
yine dünyanın en büyük Global kahve
markası
bu kahve markası kahve satarak o
imparatorluğu yaratmıyor ne yapıyor
biliyor musunuz siz onun kartlarına para
yüklüyorsunuz
ve bütün dünyanın yüklediği paralardan o
dünyanın en büyük bankalarının elinde
olan parasal stoğa sahip şu an ve
aslında bir Finans şirketi bir kahve
şirketi değil
yaptıkları şey çok stratejik yaptıkları
şey konu belirlemek
detaylamak denemek ve Yeni konular
yaratmak
ve başka konularla Rüzgar nerede doğru
giderse aynı zamanda orada olabilmek
şimdi
bu tüm bunları yap
bütün bu tekrar tekrar dene konuları
baştan ele al farklı konular yarat
yine sana şanslı diyecekler bu arada
o değişmeyecek diyecek ki ya Tolga Ne
şanslı adam ya Baksana arabasına Bak
Hayatına bak Evine bak tamam Bu bir
açıdan mantıklı Çünkü Evet ben bir
portföy Yarattım onu yaptım bunu yaptım
şunu yaptım bazılarına da o felek
vurdu Evet güzel
ben bu açıdan şanslıyım Evet
ama o feleği nasıl çevirdiğimi de ben
biliyorum değil mi
o yıllar boyu o feleği nasıl metot
olarak işlediğimi ben biliyorum
Dolayısıyla iki bakış açısına da hak
veriyorum
ama
Burada şunu atlamamamız lazım
Eğer
hareket almazsan hiçbir zaman ihtimali
olmayacak
Eğer
ihtimalleri arttırmazsan hiçbir zaman
şansın o kadar yüksek olmayacak
Eğer konuları arttırmazsan Rüzgar hiçbir
zaman her estiğinde senin yanında
olmayacak
Eğer şansın
sadece
Talihe bağlı olduğunu düşünüyorsan
hayatta çok fazla şey ıskalıyorsun
demektir
Ben şimdi size tekrar sormak istiyorum
şanslı mısınız
harika teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]